We're obsessed with our cellphones.
Sometimes for good reasons,...
...other times, we check for likes and check and check.
Or read intriguing articles about, well, never mind.
And have you been out to dinner lately?
We think we can't live without our phones.
So why don't we use them to help provide...
...something people actually can't live without: clean water.
At uniceftapproject.org, you can do just that.
Give clean water to a child in need...
...by taking a challenge to not touch your phone.
The longer you go without your phone,...
...the more you can help UNICEF put children first...
...by providing them with clean water.
15 minutes can help provide a child with clean water for a day.
Every minute counts, so keep going.
Go to uniceftapproject.org.